you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
egypt's environment minister tells sky
news they can hold the big emitters to
their cop promises as they prepare to
take on the presidency
argentina heads towards a
record-breaking heat wave as
temperatures soar over 40 degrees and
the power supply struggles to keep up
with demand
and how some conservation strategies
designed to protect red squirrels are
having the opposite effect
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now will the world's biggest emitters
keep their promises on reducing
emissions in order to limit global
warming to 1.5 degrees
egypt is preparing to host the next cop
summit in november and part of its role
will be to keep up the pressure on some
of the wealthiest nations
but some of those big emitters like
russia and china invest heavily in the
country our climate reporter victoria
seabrook sat down with egypt's
environment minister to discuss the
challenge ahead
china has been a key player with us in
so many uh
relationship at the bilateral and the
multilateral level we will discuss with
all the emitters whether they are the
big emitters or the least emitters on
how best can they
take over with their responsibilities
egypt is a lower middle income country
it's not a g20 economy
how is it going to put pressure on the
big economies and the big emitters to
make the cuts and come up with the money
that was promised at cop26 and that is
needed ever more urgently the idea is
not whether you are a low middle income
country or a one that is part from the
g20 the idea is that how you are able to
start that kind of discussion in a way
that would be useful to the humanity
when you come to see the partners that
are there whether the us coming back to
the convention to the paris agreement
and putting more pledges how can you
liaise with the european countries all
those are means of way of having those
kind of bilateral relationship and good
bilateral relationship in order to keep
the boat going forward and trying to
reach that kind of consensus a crucial
part of these cop talks is the
participation of civil society and the
right to protest but many observers are
concerned that those rights are severely
curtailed in egypt do they right to be
concerned why would they say that if a
country has already adopted a national
strategy for human rights we have our
own law that passed over to the
parliament on the civil society
participation we have announced 2022 as
a year for civil society how can a
country take all those bold steps
at the legal level and at the
institutional level would not do so it's
it could be very contradicting that is
enough answer for that well human rights
groups say that some 65 000 political
prisoners are being held in egypt these
are the human rights infringements that
they point to and that they say suggest
that egyptian civil society will not be
able to participate in cop 27. egyptian
civil society will not be able to
participate know the civil society that
that concerned with the climate changes
and environmental global
challenge will be participating in the
cup 27. so we can look forward to
free protests across the board wherever
people are from including
egyptian society we will have our own
discussion with the cup 26 with the
secretariat what is the process that we
always take in different cups and that
will be taking place in the cup 27.
egypt is hosting cop 27 on behalf of
africa
what does an africa cop look like and is
that different to other cops
african cup would look like a cop that
would put africa at the heart of
issues that are important to that
continent a continent that is very rich
in its natural resources
uh issues like
adaptation and climate finance issues
that are important to the continent not
only in africa those also vulnerable
continents of the developing countries
that did not produce emissions but they
are paying the price of the climate
change your excellency environment
minister thank you very much for talking
to us
and victoria joins me now so victoria is
the egyptian government confident then
that it can work with other governments
around the world and ensure that they
stick to their cop 26 commitments well
yes egypt says it's extremely confident
it can put the pressure needed on the
big emitters like india china the us
many others to make good on those
promises made during cop26 and one of
the key outcomes of cop 26 last year's
talks was that countries promised that
within a year they would ramp up their
action plans and egypt thinks it can
work very well even with china
which has invested hugely in egypt so
some were a little worried about how how
bold egypt would be willing to be with
china but egypt says no we've got a
fantastic relationship and we're and we
can do whatever is needed across the
world of course egypt would say that
because as it assumes the presidency of
kopp later in the year
its job is diplomacy and to get
consensus with all countries and help
them all inch forward on climate change
together but it finds itself in this
interesting position because on the one
hand it is a lower middle middle-income
country it's hosting cop on behalf of
africa with many developing nations who
are interested in things like climate
finance so funding to help poor
countries cope with climate change but
it has to represent all interests of all
countries including perhaps the very
wealthy ones who are more interested in
mitigation which means cutting emissions
and that's the key challenge for egypt
is to balance those interests
interesting victoria thanks very much
indeed
now temperatures soaring well over 40
degrees made argentina the hottest
country on the planet yesterday some
parts of the country reached 45 degrees
celsius and experts are predicting a
record-breaking heat wave as the extreme
temperatures persist hundreds of
thousands of people were left without
power as energy companies struggled to
cope with the surge in demand well
yesterday buenos aires recorded a
temperature of
41.1 degrees celsius now that's the
second highest in the history of the
capital city and in the town of new kin
the land surface temperature reached 54
degrees celsius well journalist
journalist santiago gonzalez joins us
now from buenos aires so soaring
temperatures where you are
what's the impact been there
yeah we are actually experiencing
experiencing a very strong heat wave
here in argentina actually right now we
are in a kind of relief we have 32
degrees today but yesterday i should say
before we had over 40 that was one of
the hottest days in history since we
have records here and tomorrow they say
that we're going back to the over 40s
again yesterday we have a nourish a very
strong
electrical system collapse here 700 000
people who are left without service and
in the middle of the country we are
even higher temperatures right now
yes as you said
recently 44 degrees in the city of
cordoba it's the second biggest city
here in argentina and the government has
right now issue a decree
declaring the emergency for drought in
over all the country just to fight the
forest fires especially in the southern
part of argentina the patagonia which
are
hundreds of
acres there were
burned down in the recent days
well santiago gonzalez thanks very much
indeed
now some of the day's other climate news
now and shipping container giant ap
moller maesk has announced plans to
achieve net zero emissions by 2040
that's a decade earlier than they
previously announced the company says it
will also transport a quarter of its
shipping containers using carbon neutral
fuels by 2030. around 90 of world trade
is transported by sea and global
shipping accounts for nearly three
percent of the world's co2 emissions
client earth has announced it's suing
the british government for what they
call its pie in the sky net zero
strategy the environment charity says
current plans will not reduce emissions
enough to meet legally binding targets
therefore breaching the 2008 climate
change act the government now must
submit a defense of the allegations and
the courts will then decide whether to
grant client earth permission for a full
hearing
a study has found that a conservation
strategy aiming to protect red squirrels
actually decreases their chances of
survival
conifer tree plantations were thought to
provide a safe habitat for red squirrels
and one in which grey squirrels don't
thrive however it's emerged that these
single species plantations are
encouraging pine martins to prey on red
squirrels due to a lack of biodiversity
and alternative food sources
now scientists suspect that climate
change is the cause of worsening floods
and droughts affecting south africa's
eastern coastline at least 10 people
have died and hundreds have been left
homeless after severe flooding in the
coastal city of east london at the
weekend our africa correspondent john
sparks has the latest this is the wet
season in much of south africa but
torrential rains on the east coast has
caused chaos in multiple locations
including the city of east london where
rivers burst their banks and low-lying
areas were inundated
the flooding claimed the lives of 10
people and left hundreds homeless with
the city forced to activate its disaster
management teams to keep residents alive
people living in the city's townships
and the informal settlements were
particularly vulnerable
these are the poorest areas with little
physical infrastructure where people
typically build simple homes with
corrugated iron
and in many cases their homes were
simply washed away
it's a different story further inland
however where some areas of the same
province have received rainfall for the
first time in years
in some cases the first precipitation in
seven years and when you consider that
the local economy is dominated by
farming you would think this would be
cause for celebration
but as the grass and the vegetation
began to recover
farms were set upon by brown locusts
these pictures sent to me by evan
duplessi near the town of middleburg
he said 18 separate locusts swarms flew
through his farm eating everything in
their path
and across the region officials say
thousands of hectares of grazing land
have been destroyed
so a complicated picture here of severe
weather
and the consequences of severe weather
causing misery and the loss of life in
south africa
coming up here on the daily climate show
i'm going to be joined by she who
honoree fellow at oxford's environmental
change institute and richard black
senior associate at the energy and
climate intelligence unit and we're
going to be discussing whether boris
johnson's woes are a huge distraction
from climate policy and the drive for
net zero and warming oceans and
blackouts in argentina during a historic
heat wave how can the world adapt
now we're getting straight to discussing
the climate issues of the day now with
cece who honorary fellow at oxford's
environmental change institute and
richard black senior associate at the
energy and climate intelligence unit so
hello to both of you nice to see you
both
so first of all boris johnson is in
serious political trouble again and
while not just politicians but much of
the country wait for the outcome
domestic politics drive the news agenda
so what effect does this have on climate
policy in the uk
and with the climate crisis being such a
long-term challenge is the uk or indeed
any other country with short-term
political cycles equipped to properly
deal with that challenge so let's
discuss some of those issues richard to
you first of all
there are some green campaigners who've
expressed some worries this week aren't
there that the government's climate
agenda could suffer
with a fall in boris johnson's
popularity i mean given that he has
pushed the net zero agenda do you think
they're right to be concerned
yes i think they're absolutely right to
be concerned um i think there are
several issues at play here you know one
is how much is the green agenda seen as
being boris johnson's uh uh particular
passion and then if he leaves what does
that mean for his successes who is
the likely to be the next labor leader
uh sorry next conservative leader and
currently the top two uh standing are
liz trusts and rishi sunak and nine of
them have really been massive friends of
of decarbonization i think also just the
sheer the the sheer relentlessness of
this furore around politics at the
moment just makes it quite hard to do
any sensible pragmatic long-term
policy-making in any area to be honest
well yes and we can talk about that a
little bit more in a moment but cece
first of all do you agree i mean boris
johnson facing calls for his resignation
from some quarters at least do you think
that gives an opportunity to those
looking to delay climate policies
um i think there's a bigger picture here
which is that the british public really
cares a lot about climate change and if
you look at public opinions in the uk um
it's one of those top issues that has
been um
you know on the minds of people
regardless of what's actually happening
in politics so i'm actually an optimist
in the sense that um i think as long as
people care we sustain that level of
people interest um policy will respond
regardless of what's happening richard
do you think that's right if voters want
it politicians will react
i think it would be nice if politics
generally work that way but often it
doesn't and of course in climate change
there is another issue here which is
that you can be
for doing the right things but not just
not doing them now just waiting just
being a bit pragmatic and waiting and
delaying until things get a bit cheaper
or whatever it may be until the current
crisis is over and of course if you have
so much of that delaying going on you
get to the stage where actually you're
not responding to climate change with
the speed that science says is necessary
so that would be my worry i don't think
any conservative leader is going to
publicly abandon uh decarbonization for
the reason that [ __ ] just elaborated
let alone the pressure from business but
you know as someone some people have
said delay is the new denial
and richard the uk of course still
retains its presidency of cop 26 until
it hands over to egypt in november
internationally is boris johnson's
ability to lead and put pressure on
other countries to meet their
commitments damaged at all if he's under
pressure at home
well i think it is because he just has
to spend so much attention on these
domestic issues um and of course you
know this is a crucial year for all the
reasons that we were hearing uh earlier
and it would be lovely to think that
boris johnson and the egyptian
leadership were going to work together
towards cop 27 on a joint agenda each
using their kind of influence on the
countries uh with which they have
influence but you know the way things
stand at the moment you have to think
that's not going to be terribly likely
and then if we do have a new
conservative leader a new prime minister
the question is then will they want
to spend large chunks of the year
internationally on climate change or
will they think well that was with the
johnson era and not particularly bother
and cece do you think that highlights
then the problems associated with
short-term democratic governments and
potentially dispensable leaders when
you're dealing with long-term emergency
and crises like the climate one
so i'm i'm not a political expert um but
i do i do agree with richard um here
that climate change is a very urgent
problem um and we need action now i
think the question is really how how do
we actually um kind of deal with the
issue with the systems that we have in
place right now whether it's you know
what kind of it depends you know
whatever the political or economic
system is it is working with what we
have right now but i really do i want to
go back to my point of i think
regardless of the form of government or
political system i do think public
opinion matters as long as we can keep
people interested pushing for the issue
um
there will be policy changes okay let's
turn to our second topic of the evening
and the argentinian capital was plunged
into darkness last night an historic
heatwave with temperatures hitting 45
degrees led to the power grid being
overwhelmed now also this week news that
last year saw the hottest ocean
temperatures in recorded history for the
sixth successive year
both signs of the future how to deal
with the challenges is the big question
and so cc argentina the hottest place in
the world
this week a lot of concern about a trend
of rising temperatures so what should be
the focus now is all we can do is think
about adaptation to that new normal
yeah so adaptation really has to be on
top of the agenda and we know that um
there will be a lot more extreme weather
events such as these i'm experiencing um
in in argentina right now um so we need
to think about how do we establish early
warning systems how do we train people
and inform you know
ask people to um
to know you know what they're gonna do
and also ask our city governments to
prepare our electricity systems and
companies as well how do we have enough
uh measures in place so that we can
adapt um properly to these more
frequent events and richard are you
confident that enough can be done within
adaptation to deal with the rising
temperatures and prevent the risk of
future blackouts
it certainly can be done but it costs
and of course as climate change
progresses and we see more and more
impacts the cost of adapting things will
will increase so we're not terribly sure
exactly what the cause of this um
blackout in buenos aires is but it does
seem to be that part of it has been due
to the extra electricity demand for
cooling which has put pressure on the
grid which then couldn't handle it so
ideally the electricity companies and
the authorities ought to be
strengthening the grid making it more
robust but of course if you've then got
other climate impacts coming down the
track that may sort of outstrip the
speed at which you can make the grid
more robust and it's not just heat waves
we've seen other types of climate impact
climate link should we say extreme
weather events that including in the uk
where you know we've had storms in
cumbria for example several winters that
have been uh show where climate change
has been shown to be one of the drivers
which has caused power cut
sometimes to essential infrastructure
like hospitals we've seen wildfires in
california and so on so it's some
there's an irony here in that several
opponents of decarbonization sometimes
argue that well if the world switches to
renewables we're going to see lots of
power cuts actually here is the the
world responding to climate change the
natural world responding to our
greenhouse gas emissions and it's that
that's causing us blackouts and
associates one thing uh having countries
experiencing
higher temperatures it's a whole
different challenge when you talk about
oceans as well and it's a really serious
issue warmer seas isn't it because that
means rising sea levels and more severe
storms as well so is there anything you
can do about it
well yeah the top thing is that we need
to reduce um emissions right so um if we
start producing more emissions then
we're essentially helping the slow down
the warming up speed of the oceans um i
i do think and also like because um
warming of the oceans creates more
hurricanes and flooding in coastal areas
so we we need to look into adapting in a
sense of building flood defenses and
helping protect these coastal
communities because they're going to be
very very vulnerable
okay
an issue that i'm sure we'll return to
many times but um cece who and richard
black we're out of time but really good
to see both thanks very much indeed
and that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show i'll be joined by
chidi oti obihara from the cop 26 action
plan group and former energy and climate
secretary amber rudd thanks for watching
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you